those blind to your future are
disqualified to be a part of it what
mask itself as Madness in the beginning
will eventually be recognized as genius
in the end the enemy is no match for the
faith that set that dream in motion what
the blind can't see they call Madness
our active imagination is the alchemy
that transforms spiritual truth into
physical equivalence those who display
genius those who rejected greatness
those who arose from nothing to become
something were all first laughed at
doubted and made fun of the rejection of
the world did not stop them it merely
incipient to even higher levels of
achievement what the blind can't see
they call Madness